with diplomacy
to
be engaged in diplomacy with russia and
our allies and partners to improve
stability and security in europe as a
whole
and we are ready to respond decisively
to russian attack on ukraine which is
still very much a possibility for all
the events of the last few weeks and
months
this has been our approach
and it remains our approach now
so today i want to speak to the american
people about the situation on the ground
the steps we've taken
the actions we're prepared to take and
what's at stake for us and the world
and how this may impact on us here at
home
for weeks now together with our allies
and partners my administration has
engaged in non-stop diplomacy
this weekend i spoke again with
president putin to make clear that we
are ready to keep pursuing high-level
diplomacy
to reach written understandings among
russia the united states and the nations
of europe to address legitimate security
concerns if that's
his wish
their security concerns and ours
president putin and i agreed
that our team should continue to engage
toward this end along with our european
allies and partners
yesterday
the russian government publicly proposed
to continue the diplomacy
i agree
we should give the diplomacy every
chance to succeed and i believe there
are real ways to address our respective
security concerns
the united states has put on the table
concrete ideas to establish a security
environment in europe
we're proposing new arms control
measures
new transparency measures
new strategic stability measures
these measures apply to all parties
nato and russia alike
we're willing to make practical
result-oriented steps that can advance
our common security
we will not sacrifice basic principles
though
nations have a right to sovereignty and
territorial integrity
they have the freedom to set their own
course
and choose with whom they will associate
but that still leaves plenty room for
diplomacy
and for de-escalation
that's the best way forward for all
parties in our view
we'll continue our diplomatic efforts in
close consultation with our allies and
our partners
as long as there is hope of diplomatic
resolution
that prevents the use of force and
avoids incredible human suffering that
would follow we will pursue it
the russian defense minister reported
today
that some military units are leaving
their positions near ukraine
that would be good
but we have not yet verified that
we have not yet verified the russian
military units are returning to their
home bases
indeed our analysts indicate that they
remain very much in a threatening
position
and the fact remains right now russia
has more than 150 000 troops encircling
ukraine and belarus and along ukraine's
border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
that's why i've asked
several times that all americans in
ukraine leave now
before it's too late to leave safely
it is why we have temporarily relocated
our embassy from kiev
to la vie
and western ukraine
approaching the polish border
and we've been transparent with the
american people and with the world about
russia's plans
and the seriousness of the situation so
that everyone can see for themselves
what is happening
we've shared what we know
and what we're doing about it
let me be equally clear about what we
are not doing
the united states and nato are not a
threat to russia
ukraine is not threatening russia
neither the u.s nor nato have missiles
in ukraine
we do not do not have plans to put them
there as well
we're not targeting the people of russia
we do not seek to destabilize russia
to the citizens of russia
you are not our enemy
and i do not believe you want a bloody
destructive war against ukraine
a country and a people with whom you
share such deep ties of family history
and culture
77 years ago our people fought and
sacrificed side by side to end the worst
war in history
world war ii
was a war of necessity but if russia
attacks ukraine it would be a war of
choice
or a war without cause or reason
i say these things not to provoke
but to speak the truth
because the truth matters
accountability matters
if russia does invade in the days and
weeks ahead
the human cost for ukraine will be
immense
and the strategic cross for russia will
also be immense
if russia attacks ukraine
it'll be met with overwhelming
international condemnation
the world will not forget
that russia chose needless death and
destruction
invading ukraine
will prove to be a self-inflicted wound
the united states and our allies and
partners will respond decisively
the west is united and galvanized
today our nato allies
and the alliance is as unified and
determined as it has ever been
and the source of our unbreakable
strength continues to be the power
resilience and universal appeal
of our shared democratic values
because this is about more than just
russia and ukraine
it's about standing for what we believe
in
for the future we want for our world
for liberty for liberty the right
of countless
countries to choose their own destiny
and the right of people to determine
their own futures
for the principle that a country can't
change its neighbors borders by
force that's our vision
and toward that end i'm confident that
vision
that freedom will prevail
if russia proceeds
we will rally the world to oppose its
aggression
the united states and our allies and
partners around the world are ready to
impose powerful sanctions
on export controls including actions
that
did not we did not pursue when russia
invaded crimea in eastern ukraine in
2014
we'll put intense pressure
on their largest and most significant
financial institutions and key
industries
these measures are ready to go
as soon and if russia moves
we'll impose long-term consequences will
undermine russia's ability to compete
economically and strategically
and when it comes to north stream two
the pipeline that would bring natural
gas from russia to germany if russia
further invades ukraine it will not
happen
while i will not send american
servicemen to fight in ukraine
we have supplied the ukrainian military
with equipment to help them defend
themselves
we provided training
and advice
and intelligence for the same purpose
and make no mistake
the united states will defend every inch
of nato territory
with the full force of american power
an attack against one nato country's
attack against all of us
and the united states commitment to
article 5 is sacrosanct
already
in response to russia's buildup of
troops i've sent additional u.s forces
to bolster nato's eastern flank
several allies have also announced
they'll add forces and capabilities to
ensure deterrence and defense along
nato's eastern flank
we will also continue to conduct
military exercises with our allies and
partners to enhance defensive readiness
and if russia invades
we'll take further steps to reinforce
our presence in nato
reassure itself for our allies and deter
further aggression
to be clear
if russia decides to invade that would
also have consequences here at home
but the american people understand that
defending democracy and liberty is never
without cost
this is the cause of the unites
republicans and democrats
and i want to thank the leaders and
members of congress of both parties
who forcefully spoken out in defense of
our most basic
most bipartisan most american principles
i will not pretend this will be painless
there could be impact on our energy
prices
so we are taking active steps to
alleviate the pressure on our own energy
markets and offset raising prices
we're coordinating with major energy con
energy consumers and producers
we're prepared to deploy all the tools
and authority at our disposal to provide
relief at the gas pump
and i'll work with congress on
additional measures to help protect
consumers and address the impact of
prices at the pump
we are not seeking direct confrontation
with russia
though i've been clear
that if russia targets americans
in ukraine we will respond forcefully
and if russia attacks the united states
or our allies through asymmetric means
like disruptive cyber attacks against
our companies our critical
infrastructure we are prepared to
respond
but we're moving in lockstep with our
nato allies and partners to deepen our
collective defense against threats in
cyberspace
two paths are still open
for the sake of historic responsibility
russia and the united states share
for global stability
for the sake of our common future to
choose diplomacy
but let there be no doubt
if russia commits this breach by
invading ukraine
responsible nations around the world
will not hesitate to respond
we do not stand for freedom
where it is at risk today
will surely pay a steeper price tomorrow
thank you i'll keep you informed
[Music]
are they behind the cyber attacks mr
president